welcome to the recruitment mentors
podcast my name is hisham azuz today i'm
really excited to be joined by matt
davies who is the divisional lead for
sales and marketing at arv solutions
staffing consultancy
matt has worked in the recruitment
industry since 2014
initially joining nia people in
birmingham as a trainee where he
progressed from trainee all the way to
section manager within six years where
he was leading multiple teams within the
business and then 10 months ago matt
decided to move closer to home which is
bristol
where he has now joined arv as a
divisional manager to grow and take
their sales and marketing function of
the business to the next level matt
thanks for joining me on the pod
that was a good intro i like that
yeah
so uh
let's get straight into this so where we
would like to start is the the million
pound question so what in your opinion
what characteristics and traits do you
think make up a highly successful
recruitment consultant
good question um in terms of my own this
is my opinion on this
i believe
a lot of it having coached people
is down to first of all high intrinsic
motivation i think that is something
that really
is part of someone's dna um it's hard to
learn that as a skill you can be
extrinsically motivated by a manager or
being put on a pdp or whatever that
might be but i feel to make a manager's
life easier and actually be
self-sufficient as a recruitment
consultant
a lot of it needs to come from uh within
within yourself within the fire in your
belly
and i think you need to be very highly
confident and have no fear uh just go
straight in especially for a trainee in
your first year or so i believe that you
you need to
learn a lot uh fail a lot and learn
really really quickly and stop making
those same mistakes so you just gotta
have no fear of being thrown into it
um not not really worrying too much
because you can be dealing with some
quite highly
highly status clients and candidates but
at the same time just be easy on
yourself to
understand it's going to be a big
learning curve um as i found in my first
years probably everyone did
um high emotional intelligence i believe
that
that's something again naturally i think
as you get older that always should
slightly get better from experiences
through life
um but at the same time
a lot of that is again in within someone
i believe so it's trying to spot that
ask the right questions how they
approach different situations using
psychometric tests that sort of thing to
really dive down deeper and and
understand how someone will work in
different situations
um
someone
for themselves again that constantly
probably looks at themselves and wants
to improve um
and and learn that could be
not not even in recruitment it might
just be in life it might be in a hobby
and sport
uh
but there has to be i believe some sort
of elements of coachability because in
any job in any sector everything is
always changing it's always getting
different especially with the likes of
covid or situations brexit whatever that
might be
it's being able to react to your
environments well and want to learn
um for yourself and want to i suppose
try and be successful within whatever
arena that might be 10 perm
sectors
it's all a little bit different isn't it
horses for courses
and then finally
you can have all that but
if the commercial
acumen uh is probably the best term
commerciality thrifty if you wanna if
you want some deals
um i just think that comes i don't know
i don't think that's
you might make you might think i'm wrong
but i just think you naturally want to
get a deal or you and actually enjoy
negotiations
um and actually want to be able to
have your services and believe in a
price and
spot i suppose passes as we call them in
recruitment where a bit of intel or a
bit of information might be able to lead
to
uh further fees or revenue down the line
for yourself but
that's that's difficult to teach that i
think that's more from
the dna so a lot of this has come back
to dna and testing it out but those are
the bits that i like to test out
personally
yeah that's really interesting i think
really interesting yet that you
reference a lot of things that
um
that can't be taught
but maybe you can be cultivated or
learned but i think
the part that i just what i found
interesting yeah you're curious about so
you've mentioned the first thing there
before we sort of start talking about
your early years in recruitment
being intrinsically motivated
nice little word that in it
yeah what would you what do you mean by
that
so
you get intrinsic motivation which is
myself matt davis
hisham you've got your own intrinsic
motivation like doing this podcast
whatever that might be um we all have
our goals in our own life and personally
my own goals are
what drive me to want to do recruitment
and be successful in my life i've got my
own plans by by 40 it'll be now 30. so
um those are what drive me intrinsically
every day to try and do the best job i
can in the limited amount of hours with
the clients and candidates i've got
um
extrinsic motivation so that is from
external sources so like if you went to
the gym personally i can go on my own
i want to be in good health if you're in
recruitment you might want to put good
fees on the board
um just as a bit of a comparable there
whereas it's intrinsic it's like if you
need someone like a pt it's fine and if
you work this way it's fine
extrinsically motivated you might need
someone there
potentially
beating you with a stick if you're that
type of person um you might need them
there just for the emotional support so
you get there or you've got
accountability there
personally for me as a manager when i
was managing a slightly larger team um
if you've got so many that are
extrinsically motivated it can be
difficult to keep them constantly there
ticking over
with your own job if you're a billing
manager like i was um it made life a lot
easier and i felt like
the recruiters were a little bit more
successful if it was more from within
rather than externally someone put in
that
putting that motivation there for them i
believe both is great and you need both
um especially accountability but i just
personally felt that the recruiters i've
seen do really well um for a longer
period of sustainable time rather than a
high and a low
they it just all seemed to come more
from within and
yeah more intrinsically
rather than someone there um helping
them along the way if that makes sense
that makes sense so just got two points
for you on this which i think people
find useful
so
first one
is what are like practical good
questions people listen to this can ask
themselves that maybe you ask yourselves
or check yourself on that can i guess
uncover or tap into what those intrinsic
motivations are of interest
um so what when i'm doing an interview
or when i'm doing um as in like so
you're saying you're you're you're
saying obviously intrinsic motivation is
important you're saying that that's yeah
that's something that you've had so like
what questions did you ask yourself so
no no what questions you ask yourself to
like i guess uncover and really
understand what that is out of interest
because i think a lot of these types of
things come from good questions that you
ask yourself
um yeah for me it's what my personal
success looks like for myself um
everyone is everyone's is different and
it's a question i i ask people in my
teams like why do you
recruitment's hard it's champagne and
razor blades
industry at times and um
it's knowing why they turn up for work i
think um
what
what it means to them to be successful
because i think it is an industry where
you want to be successful you can earn
some decent money you can progress
through the ranks you don't really need
a degree or anything from uh i suppose
life or college or school to come into
this but
the questions i think i personally ask
myself are
what do what do i want in the next five
years what's my next 10 year plan how
can my
recruitment career
facilitate that for me because it can
it's looking at
what controllables i have which are
putting money on the board for a
business and in return what do i get
back from that
so that's what intrinsically motivates
me which is generally money
monetary and then with that monetary
what can i invest in in terms of my own
goals to make my personal life outside
better for myself um because i like
freedom i like financial freedom that's
what personally
really motivates me
um
but i'm different and everyone's is
different it might be someone
that has
a point to prove i've seen people that
have always been
as i know just run in the middle they've
done done different jobs in customer
service or other forms of life retail
which is very difficult loads of hours
don't really get much back from putting
a good effort in there's nothing in it
for them
but then they start putting the the
effort and time into
a career such as recruitment and then
financially they see the benefits of
that to them
um and then they're able to buy the
house that they've always wanted they've
been able to get a motorbike or go on a
holiday of their dreams
it's really understanding i think going
back to your question
um what you want to do in your life
and how
your work and recruitment can facilitate
that for you
because
it is a commission-led industry i don't
know yeah i don't have i don't know many
many if any you'd probably be better at
telling me this but don't have a
commission scheme i don't know
uh firstly i don't think i could do the
job if there wasn't one
um but yeah i think that that is it is
learning
um
how you work
and how you can get the best out of
yourself
to
show up every day
because sometimes it is hard to show up
especially if you're not having the
results in this yeah yeah
so no thanks for sharing that and then
the other point that i had well i'm
going to have two now and then we'll
we'll move on to this but i think that's
pretty cool sorry yeah so that the next
point is so on that
and let me let's keep this short and
sweet on this but i'm just interested i
think
i think i think this is where people
find i know i've struggled with this so
like i get what you're saying there and
i think if you're listening to this and
you haven't taken a step back to think
about where you want to be in five years
what you want to achieve personally not
just i want to build x like you need to
think about that right but two i think
what makes that what actually will make
people actually achieve that is then
constantly
checking in with that so how often
do you like look at or think about or
yeah like look at right okay this is
where i want to be in five years or
these are my goals like do you look it
on a weekly basis do you remind yourself
on a monthly basis i think it's easy to
think about these things that begin in
the year then some people don't even
think about and we'll look at them again
until the end of the year yeah we all i
think i think it is embedded in most
pdps uh it should be if it's not um
personally i i
i'm just i don't know we i met a guy it
was called pete and uh he had his goals
written down in a diary and he said to
write them down every day
okay
i'm not i i did actually do that for
three months and um i think this is
where it really really struck with me um
that how much they change
um
when i when i used to sit down with
people going through their pdps and
their goals at the start of the year and
then
yes they might have written some of them
off there but they were so different
when we when we sit down in six months
in in 12 months time
so
um
it's hard to do every day i i personally
do every day
i don't write down every day i'm just
trying to evaluate where i'm at in my
own life because life changes um and i
think for me a career is being
successful in my career is quite
important to me i've realized that very
self-aware
and not everyone is like that um
like i do my job to have a good to live
i don't live to work if that makes sense
yeah that makes sense so you remind
yourself every day that's interesting
yeah i do the same but that that just
really works for me so okay then the
final point obviously you're 30 years of
age now you've got
more wisdom right yeah a lot of people
listen to this will be uh
younger than that right like you said
recruitment obviously has a reputation
of that champagne and razor blade so
when like you said you obviously can own
good money and
the likelihood of you then spending that
on obviously getting a table in
nightclubs when they're open and just
all that crap basically like the
question i have for you because i don't
think i get spoken a lot about in
recruitment you said one of your major
goals is financial freedom so the one
simple question i have for you is what's
been the best financial advice that
you've had in your life so far i'm not
sure invest in bricks and mortar
okay that's pretty much it um
i i've dabbled with investments um
i've read books i've i've been doing it
for about a year and a half it's just
not me mate um unfortunately my brain
doesn't work that way it's too much info
uh and it i think it's a job that i
probably need to do full-time so
um i just personally feel like investing
in bricks and mortar you're never going
to lose your money um
property property yeah
teammate
okay nice interested into that okay cool
because i don't think many like young
people think about that right and i
think it's it's important to have think
about these things sooner rather than
later
when i was younger like it's not a
problem as well but everyone will tell
you but it's it's down again it's down
to you uh that's what i mean when i was
25 i did i wasn't doing it i wasn't
interested
yeah okay so
right
early days in recruitment early years in
recruitment talk to me how obviously as
we all know it it can be some of the
most challenging periods of
our recruitment careers so basically
worked at near people for six years
like talked to us about the first
couple years how how would you describe
them i love recruitment it's uh it was
awful mate my first three months i hated
that
uh i was basically i was basically on
the line to getting fired uh i won
at the time when when mia was there we
had two we had two business um directors
owners
uh i think one wanted to get rid of me
straight away uh and i was working for
them the other i don't know what they
saw i mean to be honest because i didn't
see anything in me i was from hereford i
was very naive not commercially astute
at all basically everything that i told
you we looked for i didn't really have
it
too much but it was deep down so it did
come out from from recruitment um really
struggled
um
i started in facilities management doing
a perm desk recruiting engineers just we
didn't click um
never spoken to them in my life
haven't really since
and then uh i i got switched into this
my manager at the time and the owner
were like all right we'll take a punt on
this geezer he's all right he's probably
not got the best fashion sense but we'll
keep them in the business
and they put me on a desk that no one
had ever done or just dabbled on so i
did put a temporary public sector
property and surveying recruitment
purely into local authorities
universities and nhs so how much red
tape is there masses
we weren't on any rpos we weren't on any
frameworks uh just me
really not knowing what i was doing and
i got very successful at doing it
around the back door getting the clients
right business plan somehow
and uh and going from there and i think
i think it was the best thing for me
they just chucked me into it was there
for support
and
i think i had to learn
the hardest way
doing it all from the get-go with no
branding no one really knew me no one
knows uh and i loved it because it was
all me i'm myself my personality they
probably didn't know what to think being
in the councils and local authorities
but
it just it just really worked i had such
a good role model to look up to
uh just copied him
he was doing it for housing associations
at the time
and we both just we just both really
worked so collectively well together
uh and it was a lot to do with filling
jobs rather than candidates to market
okay so couple of things here to unpack
right for people so so just for context
yeah so when you then got switched to
that public sector desk that you
obviously had to build from scratch yeah
and how long did you end up then doing
that for
uh on that particular desk um
[Music]
so did three months on there uh been
about three years
three years and then after that is that
after that you went into leadership yeah
well i was
uh no in the third year of that i
started growing a tiny little team
all within
again haven't had any training in
leadership
but this was this was the beauty of nia
um we were all going through such a
growth phase and everyone didn't really
know what was going on but yeah i think
collectively we all had the same goals
in mind so we just had to
make those practically yeah yeah yeah
you went into a bit of a leadership off
towards the end of that then yeah yeah
went into leadership uh on the third
year of my career cool right so let's
unpack this a bit cool right so first
thing i want to know is so a lot of
people will be struggling or um have
struggled so let's just talk a bit about
that very quickly what so you said there
what were the like the main one or two
things that you really struggled with
that nearly led you to obviously being
one of the many people that fell in
recruitment in those first couple of
months so you said that you didn't
connect with the people you're speaking
to that's obviously a factor what else
did you really struggle with was it like
was yeah was you willing to pick it up
was it dynamicness everything i wasn't
dynamic i was slow
uh attention to detail the emails were
sending uh it was more just lack of pace
i was just so we've come from a golfing
environment where we just chill and we
sell marshmallows um and we coach like
all i did was coach me so i come into
this fast-paced industry i was like what
is going on i've just moved to
birmingham that's another culture shock
recruitment
ultra shock
i was just shocked mate i didn't really
know
um i was just slow
commercially awful with terms clients
would just walk all over me i had no i
had no control of candidates
uh just didn't get it mate at all yeah
you were [ __ ] basically
yeah
i was still build i still did about 10
grand in my first three months but oh
fair um i think it was seven grand yeah
there was a guy
yeah why oh what is it what was his name
uh sim sim you'll never forget your
first uh yeah
i didn't even know if he had a passport
at the time he was a refrigeration
engineer but he did luckily
so okay so basically it's just to be
fair it seems like there's a lot of
change in your life it was adapting it
was pace energy among something okay
cool yeah so then let's talk about
obviously then obviously you mentioned a
couple of things but then obviously then
went into
this temp desk it gave you a chance
there had to build it from scratch and
then this is where it seems like build
confidence had more success this is
where you really liked yeah got improved
right yeah so let's unpack this a bit
then because we obviously people
listening will want to know what did you
do differently what what were the sort
of aha or lightbulb moments that really
clicked for you and then what i also
want to know
is like i guess what i want to know is
you said that you had a really good role
model so i want to know you said you
could be there
that was most of it actually really okay
why don't we start there then let's
start there what what was it maybe like
what were they like i don't know top
three things that you really learned and
took from this person that really
changed things for you out of interest
could be on the media side
i hope they're not so there's no there's
no personal stuff in this but um yeah
when i first came in um two the two
people i
was reporting into
uh a bit more old school i felt i was a
bit more
not scaremongering but i definitely was
scared i was actually nervous as hell
being in the business if i got something
wrong the impacts of if it went wrong
uh i was just on you know when you're on
eggshells i don't know if you have
anything that's not good patience again
no i was just mad and that's why i was
making so many mistakes because you know
when you're overthinking everything
you're just like
yeah well what's going on so as soon as
as soon as i moved over and i had this
other leadership and this role model to
look at
i just relaxed and i was
able to be myself which is what you've
got right now uh before it was somewhat
nervous very unconfident couldn't really
um couldn't really do any
conversationals and
i was just in an environment where they
accepted mistakes and i felt
okay because i was in this new industry
i feel like especially when you're
cutting your teeth at this it's so much
about the environment um that you feel
at peace
and have that
a bit a bit of leeway obviously you want
the training embedded and you want to be
able to do it correctly but if those
little mishaps happen because there's so
much to do in recruitment
it's it's understanding and being
empathetical and then showing you what
you should be doing quickly
so that's what they did they just let me
do me
make loads of mistakes and i'm just a
type of person from the mistakes i will
learn um
because if you're not this is the this
is the difference so when you are
constantly making the same mistakes
that's when potentially you need to exit
uh or you need to look at
the methods of training that's being
delivered because something's not
clicking there
um but they just they just used to say
oh it's a training issue and once we
went through the training i've got it
i'm quite intelligent
that's when results started to happen
and money started to just come through
the door on its own
um i think the commitment and the effort
was always there it was just a tweak in
actually what i was doing because i was
the type of person just to if i was
showing i'll just give it a go and do it
but i think because i had that role
model and believed and i saw him doing
it and and he was just so suave he was
like brad pitt mate he's a lovely guy
i just wanted i just wanted to be like
him mate really and then then and then i
started billing the same sort of amounts
as him and it was beautiful it's a
beautiful bunny relationship how's that
yeah so okay a couple of things then
yeah so
the first thing that i want to ask you
is a lot of people listen to this will
make mistakes
so what was your process
framework of going taking a mistake and
actually learning from it because i
think it's easy to say that you do that
but how did you make sure you didn't
keep making those mistakes like once you
made a mistake
what was the process yeah if you knew if
you knew the business uh you'd
understand but if you made a mistake
it was usually a call back straight away
um it was in a nice way
doing it hands-on straight away um the
environment was very much like you're
around your team you're all listening
there are set hours when you're on the
phone um they're very hands-on and and
personally that's what gets the best out
of me if you're hands-on and i'm just me
though you've got to remember everyone's
slightly different and that might not
work for another recruiter
and i think they just the beauty of
those guys where they understood how i
worked and just did it like that for me
so like just let him get on give him the
autonomy when he when i hear him doing
something incorrectly or when i'm
when i've done something that that
wasn't quite right
that's when they grabbed me mate
right what's what's your process what
are you doing here
and then be nice with me and be like why
don't have you thought about doing it
this way or all this way and just going
through a different scenario so then i
was actually using my own brain and
being like oh yeah that makes sense but
because i never thought that way of
thinking
yeah it showed me the way of thinking
that was probably better than what i was
doing in in just the way that i learn
very quickly so
going back to how it probably is best
again it's that self-awareness factor of
understanding how you operate to be able
to tell your manager for them to get the
best out of you as well so okay
i didn't know that at the time but
looking back
they nailed it on that yeah yeah so okay
cool fair enough and then the next thing
then so obviously people want to know
like what were the main changes that you
maybe one to three things that you
changed about the way that you were
doing things that had the most impact on
your success out of interest on maybe on
the
client side maybe leeds talk to me talk
to us about that what my lead
track is mate oh my needs some what
sorry straight a tracker
uh it's absolutely brilliant if you're a
tent consultant it's basically just
tracking every temp
ever that's working for one of your
clients getting them on your database
and on a spreadsheet and that's
literally it i just tracked i think i
had 138 temps
um that weren't mine that were in
someone else's pocket and my job was
about getting them onto my
pocket out of theirs and then
backfilling the job that they are in and
i'd double up so
it's market share i basically mapped out
my market as best i could
um apart from birmingham city council
because that was just locked and i
couldn't get in it and there was at
least probably 300 attempts in a nest
there so i'll just let them guys have
that but it was looking at all the other
authorities
who was in there within the property
department that wasn't working for me
me talking to them understanding their
rates understanding what their
motivations are usually they were
getting ripped off from a margin and i
would
at the earliest stage i would it would
be monetary but then as it got better
and better and our relationships
regressed that's when i could stretch
the margins um for the clients and
obviously get that monetary value back
and when i was doubling up it didn't
matter if the margin was slightly less
because two margins would always be
equating to a bigger margin than that
one person that i was pulling out does
that make sense yeah it makes sense so
trader tracker was incredible hiring
managers
targeting those just you have to be
there understanding your competitors how
they work
um
mine was a guy called louis uh and it
was nick and louie's temps mcmasters he
still does it he's a fantastic guy in
public sector
um understanding how they operate to be
able to nick some of their
their their candidates because they had
so much share some of these guys
that they couldn't manage it and that's
where i could come in and that's why
yeah so what out of interest and on this
for people listening to this are temple
contracts like what
like let's just put aside like monetary
so as in like give getting them a better
rate or whatever like what were the main
levers that you typically pulled that
gave you the best chance of them
deciding to go with you rather than
louis who they've worked with for the
last year
a lot of it for the a lot of it for a
contract tent worker was over longevity
of the contract that was always
brilliant but in a council
they would start three months and it
would last like a couple of years
um and it was a brilliant desk because
once you got them in there you just had
to look after them um
a lot of the time what i did was speak
to the clients understand the charge
rate and then i would get the candidate
and understand their pay rate and i
would be talking to the client telling
them what they were paying the candidate
and it would be sometimes
a very solid margin and then i would
tell the candidate what they were
actually charging the client so
sometimes i was squeezing their margins
and they weren't even moving um
and it would disrupt my competition i
know i just i just know they would have
known that but i think it was more the
fact of utilizing the intel and building
really good relationships with these
people that weren't even my um workers
and i was speaking to them more than
their own
consultant so i felt it was an element
of trust and i was given this
information that they weren't privy to
and then that built that relationship
before i had even had them on the books
and i told them the margins that i would
be operating at and i told them the
industry average and what they
previously had so it was still really
strong
but i was just completely transparent so
i think it was having that transparency
factor and that's probably where i stood
out with the candidates in that market
and then was you transparent with what
you were charging when you got them on
pretty much which i think is can be
positive and negative um but i told them
after a certain period of service i'd
i'd increase it so some of the time if
they've been there a year they'll get an
increase and that'll come out my margin
and i was quite upfront about that
sometimes i'll get it back off the
client but
it was one of those it depended on my
relationship but i was very much
i like to get out there meet them
uh get them a piece of cake like that
that wasn't happening with a lot of them
and it was a lot about being out there
and actually present with these with
these temps to build the relationship
and then they would give me the leads
they'd call me and say look
thingamajig's got this could you get me
in there instead or
thingamajigs come to me with this do you
want do you want it and because i put
invested time into them they were giving
me quality intel and that's what i told
them i needed and i'll look after them
if they could look after me back so it's
a bit of a like a relationship in life
just a two-way street
um
yeah your competitors i'd love to hear
the conversations about you in other
rooms that they [ __ ] hated you mate
oh no it's all right i'm a nice guy
i think i think what i think what's
important about that is like like you
then you then didn't like you then
didn't do what they did if you get what
i mean when you then we're working with
these people i think that's that's cool
you have to do that yeah that's what i
mean yeah yeah like i think that's the
most important thing i take from that is
like what people listen to like matt's a
bit of a rat for doing that right
or whatever and then it's like
i'm just done
yeah that's what i mean but as in like
oh like why no one was doing that so why
why do you have to do that blah blah
blah but and then you've then been
transparent you've given them
information that typically people won't
give them you've then actually gone hey
look this is where it is and look if we
do work together this is what i'm gonna
be charging and look you just kept it
transparent and honest route and that's
obviously scalable because you're being
yourself you've been transparent being
honest yeah when you're honest yeah so
i'm in but i think that's i think that's
the most important thing is then you
weren't doing that and then like then
trying to do the same thing that your
competitors were and not telling them
and or charging as much as they were you
know what i mean it was basically they
told me they wanted and i gave it them
and that's why i think the element of
trust was there with me uh yeah
and why they wanted to i suppose
continue that relationship via ours
compared to someone else's yeah yeah so
what what i'm keen to do now so we've
got about 30 minutes left right so we've
gone into with some of the things that
you had to get really good at on the
temp side when is it near people so we
can obviously the next bit less like you
can reference like now past 10 months or
throughout your career but what i'm
really keen to go into three main things
is one
day plan time management structure is
what i want to sort of uncover with you
like what that looked like how good are
you with that but as we're talking about
candidates let's just let's just sort of
zoom in on this for a second and you can
use like right now yeah every single
recruit i'm speaking to at the moment is
saying how candidates sure it is or like
that's their number one challenge right
so what i want to know from you is like
what has been over the last 12 18 months
what has been like the most trusted and
most successful way that you've
consistently been able to
build relationships get candidates on
your side or in your network that you've
been able to support place or whatever
what's what's been your most best way of
achieving that
that's a good question um
the market i currently operate isn't
really candidate-led uh so this would
probably be going back to when i was
doing more of a candidate to market
approach um
doing technical stuff
but what i found
especially with some of the
consultancies was was just calling
candidates at work
and having a very strong pitch about why
i was contacting them at work with
clients that i wasn't currently working
with
and um
a lot of a lot of the reasons why i
would have done that would have been a
recommendation from someone that they
would have known that i'd either spoken
to prior
or
known about and asked them
because a great question recruitment is
can you tell me the best quantity
surveyor at the time that you've worked
in an apartment prior and if you get
that
yeah if you get that intel it's a call
right i'm calling you because
i've asked
uh i've just been speaking to a couple
of qs's i'm not gonna name names but
they've they've recommended that you are
the best in your department and i want
to be
i want to be associated with the best
talent with my clients so i feel like we
need to have a conversation like where
are you at you might not even be looking
you're probably not you've probably been
one of the best paid people if you are
that good
so it would be very soft um
and
it's it's building up the relationships
with those candidates you want to be
representing that are going to show your
clients you're good as well
um
so for me i just used to like to go
straight in deep and
um linkedin was a great tool for me
because all of the consultancy qs's and
pms and building surveyors are all
available online all on the company
websites
and yeah you might get a name for
yourself um but when you've been in the
offices there
try to win the business and you don't
get it
you know the office environment so you
can talk to the candidates about what
they're probably this is prior coving so
i used to say yeah i know you're in the
office this is really awkward
but blah blah blah the aim was to get
their mobile a lot of the time these
people are very commercially smart
anyway so want to know what's going on
in the market it's surprising how
much they want to know if they're
getting paid correctly and at the same
time i did help a lot of those
candidates that were recommended get a
pay rise
internally because of the intel that
you'd be giving them and that is a lot
of power and then if you've given if
you've helped someone get
five or six grand on their salary or 10
grand in some occasions because they've
been there that long
they're going to help me back and that
might be with a referral or someone else
or getting them in getting me into
actually working with that client so
um for me it was
i'm still i don't know if that's called
old school but
i just like to to call him and i felt
very confident in situations where it
was awkward doing that i mean i don't
know
make it not awkward
yeah yeah so i think what i think if you
listen to this and you one of your
questions that you don't ask your people
is who is the best ex person you've ever
worked with you need to be asking that
every single day because you can then
build instead of a traitor tracker
you've got the best people tracker or
whatever you want to call it right that
you're just building out all these names
best people and what a great a lot i
actually love that opener of like
hey like just an ego stroke isn't it
it's like hey i am calling you because
people have told me you are the best at
what you do yeah like it's all of a
sudden it's like oh wow okay yeah this
guy's made me feel good i'll better give
him my or two to see why he's calling me
and if you're recommended you want to
know who recommended it um and i all my
aim is to get their mobile number so i
can get them on my database so i can
then talk to them and then i can
interact with them i can send them
content it's going to be relevant to
what they want
and if you go in with look someone's
recommended that i contact you regarding
x position
i know you're at work
please can i have you got a mobile
number for me to contact you back on
later on at a better time
they nine times out of ten they'll give
you that mobile number um and they
appreciate um
the ego stroke as well so yeah for me i
was that was just the best way to build
yeah
what about
what about then and then just again
think obviously covered vibes last 10
months then so you said in the market
you're in now which was construction
engineering
yeah on the year so like what why so
what has been what have been sort of
some good trusted methods for you in the
last 10 months
again again um
my this is more for the technical part
of our division that is really high
candidate to market lead
um i believe it's it's
it's good quality
newsletters like sent out um on a
regular basis that they can actually
inter integrate with it's it's current
topics so it might have been remote at
the time it might have been how's your
current employer looking after you
you've got to remember that a lot of
people about a year ago were just really
appreciative of being in a job and they
might have actually moved and had a
really poor salary so there is
opportunities to to
like how a lot of it now is how are you
being looked after
and finding out from the candidates
about a company and then understanding
that company
and then comparing it to other companies
and showing them what they might be
missing out on uh because with a lot of
technical roles it can be working from
home and some of these old school
companies are missing out and we've
managed to pull a lot of
candidates out knowing how they've been
treated
right
during the last year i don't know if you
found that prior um
but again it goes back to the candidates
to be able to give you that intel
but then you have to have something to
give them first to compare it against so
it's knowing their competitors
um
getting some information about them that
might be positive that might make them
think that they want to move so
personally i know
when we when when some of the guys are
doing this
they knew how their their staff was
getting looked after which is really
poorly really old school and there was
murmurs and we used one of our clients
that we know
um was really looking after its staff
technically this technical staff and
what they were doing to look after them
so all you do is call these people that
are currently not being very well looked
after and telling them about how
another client is currently operating
with exactly the same staff and they
just wanted to go you wouldn't you
so okay that's interesting
yeah that's just
i think that that is the product isn't
it a product's either a really good job
really good company or it's a really
good candidate that you can then take to
market so we were looking at it right
okay
cool so next thing that i want to speak
to you about now that that is that that
makes sense so again i think what i
really like about this is like you've
really got good at doubling down on
intel and i think sometimes recruiters
miss this it's like sometimes they feel
like all they
the only
like they feel really good when they've
got good candidates but actually there's
a lot of other things that you have
as an asset information that you can
actually use
to leverage
you can leverage to build relationships
get out open that opportunity to get
what i mean so that's what i like when
you keep talking because these are all
things that you can control rather than
or that you have you should have rather
than like just always having to rely on
your candidates yeah it's your job to go
i'm in so yeah and you said so
yeah so okay cool so let's let's talk
there's a couple of things that i do
want to still ask around that i think
because i know when we before we started
you um were saying around the video
piece that you use that a lot so i just
want to ask like you're like touching
that but the net next thing then
business development
right maybe let's let's keep this
practical because i think some people
may listen to this would go yeah that
probably just doesn't work but it
wouldn't have worked for through blah
so like when you joined um the business
to join 10 months ago
in the last 10 months we had to do bd or
like was there like an existing basis
for you to go out would you building
things have you had additional business
so much more so much more inbound uh but
i've not personally been
a part of before or used to yeah
yeah because i i was
prior in the business it was a lot more
new business bd heavy so that's probably
one of my strengths
with neo and when we were setting out
the
permanent section
it was all new business no they hadn't
worked with us before so
coming into somewhere where there's
existing work and it coming inbound and
it's more about maximizing what you've
got
initially was so different
and again
it goes back to good basics of bds
making sure that you've got all the
right decision makers on that client
that you are maximizing it and not
losing your share so
i think that's what i've been trying to
do
i haven't had to do that much bd because
the job flow has been it's been so right
let's
let's let's talk about that then and
then maybe i can just get your like
best piece of advice for people to get
better at bd who are doing more outbound
right
so
i guess because i think this is this is
the whole thing right what you're
talking about and maybe you're still
learning this but obviously
some people call it one night stand
spot business but like obviously ideally
we want to be doing business right yeah
that's what you used to exactly so what
you've had to get better i'm assuming is
yeah mapping out businesses
understanding the key stakeholders
understanding yeah who are the decision
makers who can refer you blah blah blah
so like how like what's your advice for
people who have got a good client
they've done sort of repeat business
they might have exclusive terms with or
whatever and there's an opportunity
there to take that client from a good
client to a great client like how have
you gone about doing that then what have
been some of your
it's asking for i think not not enough
agents
actually test where their relationships
are
and tell you how do you test it then
you've got to say look what what do i
need to do to be a recruitment partner
of choice how can i get rid of my
competition if it's contingent
or
like the way we work now
we do very modern methods of recruitment
and a lot of it is it is retained or it
is exclusive and that's why our business
has gone um we've hit company records
the last two quarters running so
and the reason for that is that we've
got better at doing our more modern
records of recruitment and the clients
liked it they weren't used to it at the
start which is video tech um but now
they want it so
i think it's
ah coming back to your question
it's this is it's very difficult it's a
very good question um and it's more
about around
you want from me sorry just to get this
right more about how you
connect with a client that you've
already got to maximize it yeah yeah so
you saying you've been working with a
lot of inbounds so it's more about how
how can i get better so for example one
of the clients that might come inbound
they might typically give you in the
last 10 months they might have given you
10 rolls to work on right but you know
because of your intel that actually this
client could be as a business it may not
just be in your team it could be giving
us 30 roles because you know they've got
that team that team
and i'm assuming that's what you're
thinking about how can we get this
client that's spending 150 grand
revolvers a year to 300 grand if you see
the opportunity there so it's like how
have you gone about that is it you're
getting referrals within people
it's using internal relationships and
they're so key and you need to you need
to if you're nailing one person or one
client and you're supplying them
staff and you're delivering yeah
delivering yeah
you you have to actually have
the balls i hope
that's not meant to be sexy but you have
to have the confidence that's the best
word better word um to be able to go to
the client and get them to recommend you
um if you ask this to recruiters how
many times have you got one of your
clients to send an email to other people
in their organization recommending you
and cc and you in
it works
um i used to do that with consultancies
and it would be ideally one of the more
senior directors
if you are using a middle manager you
need to make that jump up to a decision
maker and get the decision maker to
either give you a testimonial and send
that to a manager internally so it's
just working what you've got if it's
working well
and getting it in writing and utilizing
the client to say look
we we love working with you the
candidates love it we've got
testimonials we know that when we put
them in there they enjoy it we really
understand your business we want to try
and repeat this like we want to repeat
what we're doing but with other people
in your business how do we do that and
they'll help you if you are doing it uh
if you are delivering a good service so
you need to be confident in in that
delivery piece and they're going to tell
you and if they don't want to do that
that's a great learn because obviously
you're not doing something currently
well enough
yeah it's wrong
to something
yeah and i'll say that okay that's fine
what and then you learn and then you
have these honest conversations that
actually then strengthens your
relationship because until you ask
you'll never find out but i think it's
having the confidence in what you're
delivering
um to just have a straight up
conversation and tell them
what you're looking to do or how they
can help you because you've helped them
and again it comes down to that
it comes back to that relationship
and you can only call it
face to face i feel it's very difficult
to do that over the phone yeah fair
enough so thanks for sharing that i
think what so people listening i'd
really underline i absolutely love that
question i wish i asked that question
more of like asking that direct question
of like mr mrs klein what do i need what
more do i need to do to be the preferred
recruiter of choice or whatever what a
great question that is like how many of
your competitors are asking that
question but actually being willing to
find out where you need to improve what
we need to be doing i think that's such
a great question um
back to the start when you want to
constantly learn i just want to keep
getting better for people so
if you do that
they'll appreciate it yeah yeah i love
that so what i want to talk about i want
to make sure that we box off day plans
because everyone right now is keeps
telling me how busy they are but i want
to know how matt's got good at making
sure you're busy with the right things
rather than just being busy for busy
sake right so i want to find out day
plan structures how you got good at that
but before i do
video tech video tech right would you
mind just sharing us a bit of that so it
seems like that's been really
um
influential for getting exclusive
business retained so i guess what i just
want to find out
is basically if you wouldn't mind just
giving us a bit of an overview of like
okay we use video tech but what does
that actually mean does that mean that
throughout the interview process is
money done over video or whatever
um
and then and so i just want if you could
give us that overview and then i just
want to ask you one or two questions
about that that could be beneficial for
people so how how has it been used
um so we
the way we use our ar view uh which is
currently um a software for ourselves we
we have a small fee initially up front
which is basically commitment from the
client um i'm not going to i'm not just
going to disclose what the fee is but
it's not yeah it's nice
um and that and that basically will
enable us to have four weeks on this job
if we can't provide a shortlist that's
up to their standard which is the
client's decision we'll give that we'll
give that feedback um and that's a no
quibble so there's not there's there's a
commitment piece there from the get-go
that they're not actually getting too
invested but all we want is they've put
the money down they're going to take
more time to actually go through the job
with us and we feel more confident
because they is actually a job because
there is a lot of jobs out there at the
minute so it's yeah it's digging the
ones that are actually going to be a
return on our time
and then from there
it's it's a portal system so the client
can log in um whenever they want
and um the way i personally do it i try
and get them involved in this as a first
stage interview so it shortens the
recruitment process so i say look i'm i
you can utilize me as ever you want if
you don't know how to utilize me this is
what i suggest
um but i'll have four or five questions
which are quite key for that position
i'll go through it with the candidate
um i tell the candidate obviously this
is like a movie trailer
so
you want the account you want the client
to buy a ticket to come and see your
movie so it it's not usually the best
what you're saying it's about how you
present yourself how prepared you are
um and i get
the better you can get them prepared
and it can be anything from how they
look on camera set up you name it
you have to go through with these people
if they've never done it before but if
you can get them present in such a nice
way that actually shows they're
beneficial and tell them like the
benefits to them as a candidate because
they'll get more
you already know if their cv is just
going across compared to the meeting me
um you've got more commitment from the
candidate you can get more leads out of
them they're face to face your
relationship's built as well there's so
many benefits of using it same with the
client because i like to get them on the
platform and utilizing it so they can
understand what we're actually doing and
how it can benefit them saving them time
where the candidate isn't coming all the
way over and they have to sit there for
half an hour an hour rather than a brief
five seven minute clip where they can
instantly know if they're hearing the
right signs or not and again it goes
back to that um
old school halo and horns if the
client's still there seven minutes down
the line they like him and you know that
as a recruiter and it's already
alleviated a bit of speed because they
don't have to go through that do we
actually like them
right so directly straight to the second
interview and because of the market the
minute this is cracking because you know
how quickly candidates are going um in
multiple offers they we sort of prep the
clients that if you want them and you
like them you need to get them now
and uh it's a lot the candidate is more
invested because of what they've had to
do they've had to do more prep compared
to all the others potentially so they
they're invested in this job as well so
it just helps
it helps you as the recruiter
get to the end goal
which is amazing just for the first
stage
and then it's yeah just for the first
stage and then directly um sometimes
they'll do a teams and go to offer or
they might even just go straight to face
to face and it's usually at one stage
rather than okay
thanks for sharing that so you've shared
obviously some of the positive positives
so what i want to ask you then a direct
question because i'm sure people will be
thinking this but where people can get
value is like like you said so when you
first doing this with clients they
hadn't really done it before would have
been resistant so i'm sure you have
candidates that go
[ __ ] off matt i'm not doing a video i
hate video a lot i'm not up for that you
know i mean so like talk to me about
like resistance how did you get through
this
the resistance of like matt i'm not
doing video do one like what how did you
get through that what we're quiet so
we're candidates or both
both just tell because i'm sure you've
got it on both sides how did you work
through the resistance i think with the
clients it was more monetary so if they
utilized initially when we did this it
was in lockdown covered things were a
little bit tense so we actually put a
scheme on if we went through this modern
methods of recruitment we work in a
modern methods of construction industry
so they should be bought in um because
we have that equally uh equilibrium
there so
we actually gave them a further discount
of that fee that they initially gave us
back at the end so it was for for a
certain period of time to get them on
board utilizing it because we know once
they utilized it they'd like it
it was actually the deeper option
compared to contingent compared to
exclusive so that was the way
we utilized it to get the clients on
board mainly and it worked because mds
with covid a lot of the time it was all
commercials and you can't
you know
time and money
for the candidates that were a little
bit nervous um because i do sales and
marketing for me
i didn't really have much of a
an objectional handling so i can't help
people on here that much because i said
like in sales you need to be
client-facing you have to be um so you
need to it's a good opportunity for you
to get more prepared for the modern
methods of the world we don't know when
code is happening so
just use it as a training course and i
would do a pre sometimes a pre screen
with them for 10 minutes just to get
them like training them on actually how
to do a video
because uh it was some of them mate was
so poorly done um yeah and it ended
across it just would have probably been
less than just sending a cv i'd have
more chance of getting them in that way
um
so i think
i think it's just it's just
being honest with the this is the way we
work with this client you have to do
this and then if they said no you'd ask
them why
um
and some of the times it was because
they already had a second stage
interview or they already had an offer
or they already had something else will
come out the woodwork as to why they
don't want to do it if it was a
confidence issue
generally would you really as a
recruiter want to waste your time
utilizing one of those people because
when it comes to interview they've got
to do it anyway so
it didn't that's just my industry or my
desk so i can't really add to it yeah
i think with the technical guys
it is a lot different but how much value
does it really add um for someone that's
i.t or i don't know that's that's that's
out of my arena
yeah fair enough now thanks for sharing
i think there's a we won't talk about it
now but i think
it's just interesting that because i i
do think there's a real thing a real
point in there around like interview
bias
when you're down that route you know
what i mean because i do
you know and that's a huge thing so all
of a sudden
like i can receive videos i'm gonna see
what they look like
who they are what they're about and like
that can even then in like encourage
even more
questions
i've done a lot of stuff i mean i don't
know
yeah i understand how that can really
help but i don't know i think i don't
know if that's like going to be the
long-term solution forever just because
i think that's if you are one if you are
really focused on building diverse teams
that represent the world today that we
live in and stuff
i think
seeing human beings on the screen you're
going to make even more judgments and
assumptions you know i mean it's just
how it is so i don't know i think it's
interesting but makes sense but um
and then so okay cool let's wrap this up
then with a really popular area that
everyone wants
and me to always ask people about is
like the
everyone's saying they're busy
yeah i'm assuming you're assuming you're
quite busy at the moment if you're yeah
yeah talk to me about talk to him about
day plans mate so as i said like what
what do you talk to me through let's
finish this off with like what does a
typical day for matt look like
yeah yeah yeah so for me i like to do it
uh so i've got come into the office i've
got a little board
right so what is important and urgent
today that has to be done no negotiables
like
then i mean i'll do them first because
you'll personally i'm up for it in the
morning i need to get it done i know
it's done if i can't do it i've tried
i'll come back to it at two o'clock in
the afternoon basically that's how i
prioritize stuff that has to be done in
the day
second of all um second of all i'll look
at
right what sort of tasks have i got that
are important but not necessarily as
urgent
how long have i been putting these off
for if it's longer than two weeks that's
when i need to like actually say are
they on the right list here because if i
if they've been going on longer than a
week or two
you should be doing something towards
them or you need to like look back at
what you're actually doing
that's just me personally and then
thirdly what's all that stuff that
doesn't really matter but you know
probably you should get round to at the
end of the day if you can do it
um that that's just how i begin the day
when i come into the actual office then
i'll look at my job flow what's coming
overnight
um what is where's my desk at like you
have to analyze your desk every day so
prior to coming into the day i've
actually got my day plan done
um i don't like to come in and be
reactive i like to know that i've shut
off for the day
i don't have to do all that stuff when
drinking a tea it's just there so i'll
just get on with it personally matt what
did what does your day plan look like
then
uh so it's laid out with those boxes
um all of that i've got uh an emails
that have to be sent um tasks callbacks
voicemails i just go through and i
highlight the ones that i have to do
um i've got cvs that have been sent out
or video interviews that have been sent
out that i need to chase so that's
always there which leads a hot i've got
hot leads board like if they haven't
moved in three days they're not hot lead
anymore like what have you done around
those leads that are actually gonna
hot leads i don't need to go into that
but that's just where my business
developments at which i've got a little
booklet next to me here with managers
names in and the companies to add into
the database that's at the end of the
day i need to add at least two a day um
just to make sure you're constantly
cause your database is key isn't it it's
king you need to make sure it's all up
to date and then i just have um so
between
uh like nine o'clock and then
half nine i usually got my team meeting
there so after that that's when i have
core activity until twelve um i like to
switch off and do my admin for two hours
and then i'll come back in and do core
activities
what's core activity this stuff
yes no core activity is when i'm on the
phone um
generally i like to be on the phone
between um sort of half nine half eleven
and then two until four so that just
keeps my desk from doing this going
you're doing like just just candidate
time and client time every single day it
depends
you can't you can't say that you need to
do bd um constant i've always had that
built into me because you never know
where your clients going to go if
they're going to go rpo we've we've had
this recently two big clients have just
gone rpo
um so you need to constantly be freshing
out what stripping candidate cvs keeping
your database up-to-date because there
might be business and revenue of smes
that would be going to be growing in
these markets um so you need to keep an
eye on doing that constantly it's all
constant but it's
i think it's it's learning that
experience that if you don't feel busy
and you're at work and you're like right
i need to just tick off calls here
i i personally don't believe in that
there has to be
like a reason behind things like
internationally
not just i'm not into this kpi numbering
mate um i like tasks like what's my task
now i need some jobs right how do i get
jobs where does it go from so it's all
outcome and then i go backwards and what
tasks i'm gonna do an alterating tact on
what that might look like in fact i love
that oh yeah thanks for sharing that and
i think i think key thing to sort of
highlight there from the conversation
i've been having is i think it's really
easy for people right now to because
they've got jobs coming out there is to
not do that constant bd piece as you
said but i think trust me and everyone's
learning it the hardware right where
your best customer yeah flips into an
rpo or whatever and it's like [ __ ] have
done bd for three months so
now like you want to be able to see a bd
like yeah exactly yeah exactly you're
getting a groove of it as well don't you
you get in you get confident yeah so and
also like you're definitely going to be
more confident doing bd if you know that
like you've got jobs like you know like
worst case scenario i'm i'm flying like
if you don't give me if we don't do
business sometimes that's cool i've got
all these other clients but so so
definitely highlight that and then i
absolutely love that grid absolutely
love that um i think that's really
practical for people so like if you've
got loads of ties you've got a to-do
list great but go a step further like
what is urgent and has to be done what
is urgent and made isn't as urgent what
is um isn't urgent and you don't need to
do or whatever like yeah non-negotiables
yeah so i think that's great so
final question
what
final question
final question mate is um love asking
this like if you could change the
industry what would you improve
i think personally it's just recruiters
getting on with it everyone um i still
feel like there's a bit of a stigma
in
sharing intel and sharing like knowledge
um there's enough market share to go
around
um i just whole point of this should
completely yeah
may i i just
i don't i don't feel like
it's getting better actually i think in
the last few years 100 million
but um we're all humans we're all here
on this planet there's always enough to
go around
um i just i don't know if this is a
personal thing for me i just think help
help everyone out
this job's very difficult
um it'd be nice to i think we all lack
that intel from other businesses me
personally knowing that i don't know if
you do when you were a recruiter
you've got a gist on how others operate
but i think we've all got very similar
problems
everyone's got very similar
ways and different ways of looking at it
but collectively i just feel like we
could get a bit more uh we could be
stronger as an industry if we we just
chilled a bit and and helped each other
out so we all get better
well that's that's absolutely the
mission that we're on with recruitment
mentors so i couldn't agree more so um
matt been an absolute pleasure thank you
so much yeah no problem i didn't swear